it's described as the first localized
mass testing program for the coronavirus
here like many cities Valenzuela is
grappling with a pandemic and with help
from these health workers they say
they're taking matters into their own
hands to set up their own testing system
separate from the national government
their aim is to stop the disease from
spreading the first to get tested are
some in this neighborhood described here
as persons under investigation who may
have contracted the virus or been in
contact with infected people frontline
workers such as doctors and nurses are
expected to get tested as well
previously requests for a limited amount
of testing kits had to be made to the
national government and it would take at
least a week before results arrived with
thousands of kit at their disposal and
with the hospital that can process these
tests the results should only take two
days to come through
more than 60 million Filipinos have been
forced to stay at home after President
Rodrigo Duterte declared a national
health emergency a few weeks ago
checkpoints like this one have become
familiar scenes the government says the
lockdown is necessary to prevent a
further outbreak in many communities but
more and more experts say this is simply
not enough and there are growing calls
for the government to conduct mass
testing in many communities the health
system in the country is clearly in
crisis most hospitals are full and the
number of health workers dying from the
virus continues to rise so testing
efforts like this one are seen as a
major breakthrough especially in poor
communities which usually don't have
much choice but to stay at home and wait
for help to arrive there is hope for
deliverance they say from their
collective anguish Jamel Allen doggin
al-jazeera Manila